I just want my little boy back at a news
conference Wednesday
Ian rich made a desperate plea for
anyone with information about his
missing six year old son Maddox to come
forward it's been torture
I'm not eating not sleeping I'm just
worried about getting my little boy back
Maddox has autism and is nonverbal his
father says he was last seen Saturday
afternoon at Rankin Lake Park in
Gastonia while walking with him and his
girlfriend rich says the boy chased
after a jogger and then disappeared I
couldn't catch up with him I feel guilt
for letting him get so far ahead of me
before I started running after we want
to find Maddox we want to find him today
we want to find him right now
the search for Maddox is intensifying
investigators say they are following 250
leads and combing through thousands of
acres they're using specialized
underwater equipment to scan the parks
lake they are also looking to speak with
the jogger and another man loading a
kayak into a truck at the park Saturday
gaston county 9-1-1 police released the
9-1-1 call wednesday that was made
nearly an hour after Maddox went missing
we regulate car guess on you know kind
of missing kids it didn't look as though
they were that concerned Rick Fox made
that 911 he works at Rankin Lake Park
and doesn't believe Maddox was ever
there I've worked there almost three
years and we see it everybody come in
and out of that that Park pretty much I
didn't see that kid one time